[Music]
in is this cheating news or is it love I
don't know submitted by I am chicken and
we 70 University of Texas students are
facing discipline for group chat sharing
study materials what that's been
happening wait it's thirty materials and
they finally cut them don't
what is it cheating if it's just study
materials do you think they have all
kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] like porn on the
phone all kinds of nudes and [ __ ] and
like we got you and they're like oh no
[ __ ] oh god I think I lost it like we
got your study material
yeah so about 70 students at the
University of Texas at Austin are facing
either automatic failing grades or
expulsion from being members of a group
meet what is it
cheat sheets or is it study materials so
here's the thing or answer key usually
these are answered King straight-up it's
like the thing is like this one it seems
kind of unfair in my eyes because this
group me was set up at the beginning of
the class and even the teacher and
teacher's aide are in it and Shanee so
around the time of this anthropology
courses second exam a student had posted
asking what might be on the test
like what topics and so another student
responded with the list of all the
textbook concepts that the class had
reviewed up until the exam be a good
homey but that is against the rules what
because this is an online course and
they're saying that oh like different
classes take tests like before other
people so then that's why they have
these certain rules in place Oh
to not be sharing anything about the
test period because that could be
considered cheating so shouldn't it be
like the person who shared its fall not
the one that not the people that are
involved in the group me but they all
got to see it so then you don't know who
saw and who did
then that's not their fault listen just
that's like if someone got the answer
key and [ __ ] threw it inside the
class whatever and some people didn't
pick it up some people saw it but the
whole class is in trouble
what about it's an online classes
they're taking a test I can just Google
[ __ ] am I out of my mind I feel like you
can't even claim anyone's cheating
because you do so many other resources
you could do right I have your buddy
sitting next to you and just give you
answers while you're taking the test you
could hire it and they figure that if
you're taking an online course you have
no friends
oh they're like that's not gonna happen
ta I mean that's how they were able to
find out about that and mochas a teacher
read in her mouth
I just don't get it like that's just
such a weird way teacher writing about
like the teacher was the one that is
saying like they're having it's this
whole investigation into it like the
school is investigating into what's
gonna happen to these students because
the teacher reported it saying this is
against the rules
what school is this the University of
Texas Austin we have to free these kids
this is a little [ __ ] cuz you could
have just been like hey don't do that
and then maybe they'll stop instead of
just going straight to expulsion I know
that's pretty extreme I know I would
have told them delete that [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah giving chances I keep they do say
that in the syllabus there was no one
recess yeah that's like hitting I agree
see that's why you can't have an online
course because the first day of class is
always just reading out the syllabus
really slow and draining out the
[ __ ] time mm-hmm
but see just literally run the clock
down yeah always weird when the teacher
went straight into lecture like they
just passed out this syllabus in a
wented lecture on the first day out of
been like this teachers [ __ ] up yeah
yeah great it's wrong with them I didn't
bring up pensar gonna be hard yeah what
I would have done I mean the fair thing
to do in this case cuz it sounds like
the teacher and the score being laziest
[ __ ] just give them a different test
I just switch it up now they're like
isn't it just the system's fault that
yeah you could do that yeah you know
that's pretty extreme in my book there's
kids out there at Texas [ __ ] Austin
that's selling cocaine and [ __ ] expel
those kids yeah it's like the same just
to get the coke it's like it's like what
is this there's [ __ ] answer keys
inside this [ __ ] celebration boats
big
[ __ ] I want to clarify something because
I think I miss misread something so
they're saying that the student said
that the group me link had been sent out
publicly at the start of the semester
and neither the course teaching
assistants nor the teacher had commented
on it that's what happened there not the
fact that they were in the group me why
clarify that okay now that makes them so
[ __ ] these kids now yeah [ __ ] the
students they're all yeah and so they're
saying that like one student for example
they just use this to organize study
groups tune orgies and study groups
navigate tricky links to assignments and
how people's semesters are going and
there's so she's they're saying too that
it's not fair to reprimand the people
that had the group me like with
notifications turned off or like on
silent or whatever cuz they probably
didn't even see those messages right but
there's this ongoing investigation here
I wish I knew the people that had those
answer keys in college because I
actually studied like a regular person
me too I wasted so much time studying
rap I know my cousin who went to college
after me he joined one of those like not
like a social fraternity but like the
one that's like actually in the field
and then so the last class they would
give all the answers to all the tests
and then they would learn it and then
they'd be able to pass that on and I'm
like what that helps it out so much
that's why they join fraternity yeah
before I forgot they're called not the
social fraternities but there's your
major you know the cheating ones you
know like it like there's like econ
fraternities or like medical fraternity
or psychology Furter not the one that
are just about party they're not like
the Korea teens Oh like skull and bones
of [ __ ] like hey we're gonna run the
world that kind more of like whatever
your major is I have those kinds of
attorneys do that's pretty boring yeah
but you get an turkeys thanks that makes
more sense than the social ones to me
because the social you could be social
with people in the same field as you
everyone like it's different because the
social ones are they were they were
created because everyone comes from like
different states and nobody knows anyone
so this is a way for people to like yes
yeah
they be coming yeah TIFF and they get
the FATA Lee I didn't either I'm just
trying to stick up for them yeah that's
paternity 'z they've been around for a
long ass [ __ ] time I just never knew
the purpose yeah I specifically remember
when I first came to college here
I couldn't understand which cognitive
actually Whittier College Whittier oh
yeah yeah dude you were a frat no I
wasn't um and I had them explain it but
still they don't have friends in the UK
yeah they might we're into public social
they probably have it groups if you let
me spank you 20 times you will truly be
my brother no it's just I didn't
understand I was like well what can't
you just make friends rush
Monty Bourne is cool is a ledger run II
don't know I don't know if it started
where it was a friend thing because like
I'm thinking about like the 1800s and
[ __ ] like that
like those societies those I mean those
Greek clubs and I mean some of these
groups are [ __ ] old like the Harvard
crews and all that like there's those of
all those groups but I feel like they're
all trying to copy them the old-school
guys so I'm like how the [ __ ] did that
happen because that paddling [ __ ] and
hazing [ __ ] it was more like are you
cool enough or tough enough or mentally
strong enough to be a part of our group
what sounds like the old ones and I'm
just making this [ __ ] up was more like
aristocratic like like the the wealthy
kind of kick it together and like you
get a house together and you have each
other's backs and famine our kids are
gonna be in this - yeah well you will
[ __ ] pay people to get our kids into
colleges and doors is there a difference
between society and France because I
remember in a school it was called
societies that's what you had yeah and
wait where he came here I've been
Britain they had like eternity he mainly
grew up in Japan well yeah I know
yeah I don't even know who accent really
does read that way I'm sorry I don't
know anything about England a Japanese
[Laughter]
really it's really broken up though yeah
where how many years in Japan I did a
Peter Pan reference in the previous
video he didn't even know talked to me
probably see it how did you live in your
pan for uh I was born there and then at
three I went to England and then twelve
I moved to Japan 20 I came here oh no
wonder you don't worry cuz yeah it was
the time word like you're barely growing
up like what's drinking like in England
it's like I started drinkin Japan so I
have no idea also like from junior high
and then you spent your teen years in
Japan so like you're you're kind of like
your childhood was in England and then
your teen years when's your college got
it here yeah that's really specifically
different yeah so that's well you kept
the accent though yeah I think so why
could you learn too early onlet do why
it's cooler than Japanese one I'll say
well the Japanese yeah yes definitely
what makes everything sound so damn
smart yeah it's like legit even when you
don't know I don't know it just sounds
like you know everything I don't like
that you sound smarter than Neil Tyson
to me because he has an American I don't
get tricked well I'm just saying you
sound it is just like good the other way
around
yeah what do we sound like see latest
stupidest but you know what though I was
she sounds like us I hate I where I
first came in here I felt really
self-conscious because I sound like this
but I haven't like studied studied
English in a long time right
in Japanese high schools at the level
bit [ __ ] you know so in English class in
college I was really afraid that people
would be like okay why is he sang like
this but he doesn't know that much let's
just be stupid you're about to put some
Mexicans at Whittier College too so
there's the
like I know there's more white people
maybe no it was premix oh pretty lips
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]